Mittlerweile sind allein im Osten des Kongos
2.000 Menschen an Ebola gestorben - weitere
3.000 Menschen sind an dem heimtückischen
Virus erkrankt.
Jetzt hat Bundesaußenminister Heiko Maas
das Ebola-Gebiet besucht und versprochen,
das Land im Kampf gegen die Epidemie finanziell
zu unterstützen.
Außerdem hat ein Forschungsteam zwei Antikörper-Therapien
gegen Ebola erfolgreich getestet.
Kann die Krankheit jetzt endlich aufgehalten
werden?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
“Wir können der Ausbreitung des Virus nicht
weiter tatenlos zusehen" - so hieß es von
Bundesaußenminister Heiko Maas bei seinem
Besuch im Osten der Demokratischen Republik
Kongos am 4.
September.
Schon seit 13 Monaten versuchen Teams aus
Helferinnen und Helfern, die Lage in den Griff
zu bekommen.
Doch die Seuche ist gefährlich und das Virus
breitet sich weiter aus.
Mittlerweile ist klar, dass dieser Ebola-Ausbruch
der schlimmste nach der verheerenden Epidemie
in Westafrika ist. 2014/2015 forderte das
Virus hier mehr als 11.000 Tote.
Die Situation in der Demokratischen Republik
Kongo ist jedenfalls extrem angespannt.
Denn es ist nicht nur die Ebola-Epidemie,
die dem Land zu schaffen macht.
Auch die Sicherheitslage macht es den Helferinnen
und Helfern schwer.
Es geht um Bodenschätze, um die bewaffnete
Rebellen gnadenlos gegeneinander kämpfen.
Selbst die Helferinnen und Helfer können
sich nicht sicher fühlen.
Hinzu kommt, dass manche Ebola-Opfer die dringend
benötigte Hilfe nicht annehmen, denn die
Bevölkerung ist misstrauisch.
Das liegt an Gerüchten, denen zufolge Ärzte-Teams
Blut und Körperteile klauen wollen, um damit
Hexerei zu betreiben.
Zudem kritisieren Hilfsorganisationen, dass
die Kontrollmaßnahmen am Flughafen Goma mangelhaft
seien.
Seitdem Mitte Juli in der kongolesischen Großstadt
der erste Ebola-Fall bestätigt wurde, wird
allen Passagieren Fieber gemessen.
Doch nun hat sich herausgestellt, dass bei
manchen Betroffenen an den Kontrollposten
dramatischerweise keine Infektion festgestellt
wurden war.
Und das, obwohl diese Menschen bereits infiziert
waren.
Der internationale Verbund verschiedener Hilfs-
und Entwicklungsorganisationen “Oxfam”
fordert deswegen bessere Ausrüstung und Trainings
für die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
der Gesundheitsdienste.
Bundesaußenminister Heiko Maas hat die dramatische
Situation erkannt und hat versprochen, mit
Verantwortlichen der UN über finanzielle
Hilfen zu sprechen: “Trotz großer Anstrengungen
sind die Fortschritte noch nicht so, wie man
es sich gewünscht hat".
Bislang sind es vier Millionen Euro, die die
deutsche Bundesregierung der Ebola-Nothilfe
direkt beigesteuert hat.
Deutschland ist zudem an Fonds der Weltgesundheitsorganisation,
der Weltbank und den Vereinten Nationen beteiligt
- und zwar mit einem Millionenbetrag.
Auch dieses Geld wird - zumindest teilweise
- für die Ebola-Hilfe verwendet.
Wir haben hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
immer wieder über die neuesten Entwicklungen
zum Thema gesprochen.
Ebola ist ein Fieber, das in rund der Hälfte
der Fälle zum Tod führt.
Es beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine Grippe,
aber im weiteren Verlauf fangen die Opfer
überall an zu bluten und sterben schließlich
an multiplem Organversagen.
Übertragen wird die Krankheit meistens von
sogenannten Reservoirwirten.
Das sind Wildtiere, die gejagt und gegessen
werden.
Durch die Abholzung von Wäldern rücken Menschen
immer näher an diese Populationen heran.
Durch den Verzehr von Buschfleisch - wie etwa
Flughunde, Affen oder Stachelschweine - kommt
es dann meistens zum Ausbruch der Seuche.
Eine klinische Studie, die seit November 2018
vor Ort durchgeführt wurde und die Wirksamkeit
von vier Medikamenten gegen Ebola untersucht
hat, weckt jetzt aber einen kleinen Hoffnungsschimmer.
Denn zwei der vier untersuchten Medikamente
schnitten gut ab: Die Sterblichkeitsrate sank
im Durchschnitt auf etwa 30 Prozent.
Von diesem Ergebnis berichtet unter anderem
das “National Institute of Health”: Wenn
Ebola-Betroffene nicht behandelt werden, liegt
die Sterblichkeit zwischen 60 und 67 Prozent.
Die beiden erfolgreichen Wirkstoffe mit der
Bezeichnung REGN-EB3 und mAB114 werden jetzt
auch außerhalb der Studie eingesetzt und
Ebola-Patienten verabreicht.
Die Therapie setzt auf die Gabe von Antikörpern.
Das sind Eiweiße, die das Immunsystem normalerweise
selbst herstellt und Krankheitserreger aufhält.
Die Antikörper für die getesteten Mittel
binden sich an ein Eiweiß auf der Oberfläche
des Ebola-Virus.
So verhindern sie, dass der Erreger in die
Körperzellen eindringen kann.
Dazu der Direktor des National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases” - Anthony
Fauci: “Wir können jetzt sagen, dass 90
Prozent der Patienten nach der Behandlung
geheilt sind”.
Die Studie an sich wurde frühzeitig gestoppt,
damit die anderen beiden Medikamente, die
die Sterblichkeitsrate nur schwach verringert
hatten, nicht mehr eingesetzt werden.
Rund 680 Patienten wurden in die Studie aufgenommen,
deren offizielle Veröffentlichung für Herbst
2019 geplant ist.
Der Medizinstudent hat ein Video dazu gemacht,
in dem er die Krankheit medizinisch natürlich,
nochmal deutlich besser erklärt.
Anklicken, anschauen und Der MEDIZINSTUDENT
abonnieren.
Meine Empfehlung auf jeden Fall.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!